i want to revisit where we've come from
because uh frankly in going back to find
photographs to remind myself of where we
came came from in the pandemic uh you
know i knew all of this but it was
jarring actually to see some of the
photographs from the beginning so zach
do you want to begin to show those and
i'll describe them for people who are
just listening these are from march of
2020. two years ago two years ago um so
uh just to revisit heather and i were in
the amazon finishing the first draft of
our book and heard about novel
coronavirus for the first time as our
phones came awake after
uh being in complete isolation where
there was no service of any kind so that
was january that was january um so we
returned and the story of uh novel
coronavirus which became uh stars kobe 2
and kovid uh
marched on so what this is a picture of
here
some of you will remember that early
dark horse episodes were not live
streams they were all discussions
between me and somebody uh in person
and they were in a different place
we built this studio into my office as
covid forced us out of the studio that
we were renting in downtown portland and
so this is
too soon right this
is a photograph zach and i recaptured
everything we could from the studio
downtown in a mad rush we were literally
going into the building at midnight so
we wouldn't interact with people because
nobody knew how this thing spread and
how dangerous it was i think it was
literally i'm just looking at the
calendar like we are literally two years
to the day from the last day that zach
was in school the following day was
toby's last day of school and then that
weekend is when you guys
right uh emptied out the studio so the
kids were thrown out of school on mass
zach and i
took the dark horse studio and took
every piece that would move and brought
it home
and started going to the hardware store
to get the kinds of things necessary to
make the studio work so like the
interior of asana
right like the materials from the
interior of asana cabinets and the like
all right so go ahead here an image
okay so at this time
there was
a hoarding of and i don't want to say
hoarding i think that's actually the
wrong term people were stocking up on
materials not knowing what was coming
and actually i don't think they were
wrong in this regard we have now seen
supply chain issues yes they were
delayed but of course the idea that we
were in a unstable situation and that
one couldn't guarantee that staples were
going to be available was very much in
the air i thought all the supply chain
issues were due to putin's invasion of
ukraine is that not right no because of
times arrow oh yeah yeah right it's
right it's funny how no one in the
mainstream media seems to know yeah the
inflation also turns out to have been
well underway before that
yeah yeah all right uh go advance uh so
that was beams that were uh out of stock
interestingly people spotted that uh you
know black beans uh were the right thing
but there were lots of other beans they
left on the shelves
yeah lentils were almost always
consistently available actually good to
know and actually i didn't include a
picture here but i had a picture of the
peanut butter section
where people have not spotted just what
a good staple that is
so you could buy peanut butter even if
you couldn't buy beans this is
surprising to me you got a whole bunch
of dr bronner's on the bottom shelf
that's castile soap that stuff saves
forever you can do it use it for almost
anything you want to clean yeah yeah i
know the deeper you read into that
bottle the more things you discover it's
good for it's um
there may be a little evangelism there
but okay um oh yeah
dude was a little out there but you know
here we got hand sanitizer has been uh
ransacked now notice
um hand sanitizer didn't actually turn
out to be important here but we all
thought it was going to be very
plausibly so now hand sanitizer is good
stuff and a lot of infectious disease
that we spread around colds and flu and
the like um is likely very sensitive to
it so i don't resent the
bias towards hand sanitizer that we've
moved to but i
we all remember
the uh the craze around uh isopropyl
alcohol which you couldn't get
and um hand sanitizer which turned out
to be more or less irrelevant to covet
yep um okay advance one more
now here this is a line
out the door
at the local gun shop right people were
hoarding now i gotta find a better term
people were stocking up on guns and even
more importantly ammunition and it was
resulting in a store that would never
typically have a line having
a line out the door i wrote a little bit
about this uh for unheard where i
discussed the question of the second
amendment and what role um
it may actually be playing but anyway
that's the local gun store and the the
line that existed there can you go one
more
and here you can see a wall of um ugly
duckling guns that people didn't really
want
but you can see how many spaces are
empty on that wall right as people are
buying now the thing that was really in
short supply was ammunition that's
that's a wall that normally would have
been full every spot would have had a
gun and um and it got it dwindled more
than that
um
but it was it was the ammunition that
that just simply wasn't available
anywhere much like hand sanitizer okay
advance one more
all right now here
is why i was going back to look for
photos
i was one of the first people to mask in
portland i was so early that i was the
only person at the hardware store zach
and i were
getting materials to build the studio
here
um i was going in masked with those are
safety glasses with a little bit of
reading glasses
in the yeah and they have side flanges
yeah and i had a technique and the basic
idea was nobody knew how this thing
transmitted at that point
we were talking about formites and very
high cfrs and all this so it stood to
reason that a mask was a good idea even
if nobody else was wearing them maybe
especially if nobody else is wearing
them it stood to reason that because
many viruses do get in through your eyes
that having safety glasses on was a good
idea
and in order that they didn't interact
badly with my reading glasses i got the
reading glasses built in i also uh used
cloth gloves you could buy a like 10
gloves for five ten pairs of gloves for
five bucks and i would put them on wear
them while i was out so while i touched
things and then i would strip them off i
would actually early on strip off all my
clothes when i got home and put on new
clothes so if this thing was
transmitting on clothing
right you and i had you your discovery
was that copper
actually
i've covered our um outdoor and indoor
to outdoor doorknobs with copper tape
copper because copper uh is both an
antiviral and antibacterial right we had
a policy that when and it looks nice
when packages arrived in the cardboard
box as they all do we would leave them
sit for 24 hours because the evidence
was that infectious agents couldn't
persist on cardboard for longer than
that so anyway we had an elaborate uh
routine that was based on the fact that
we really knew very little about this
pathogen and one of the things and we're
trying to be careful we were airing in
the in the direction of being careful
because we took this virus very
seriously for reasons we will get back
to you later
but
i think one of the things that i hope
people will remember about us is that
what what we really did and what got
people's attention early on when we
started live streaming your idea that we
start live streaming from here was it
yep it was your idea um so you're in
good company joe rogan suggested that i
start a podcast you suggested that we
start live streaming yeah well we were
sitting i do remember this we were we
were
we were pulling our hair out about the
public health pronouncements already at
that point they were so inconsistent
they seemed to be based on no data or
patently absurd analyses
and i and yeah i think i said to you
something like i really feel like we've
got a lot that we can offer in terms of
how to think through these things even
though even though we knew this and
therefore we knew that there was
a substantial risk um that we could have
been
really wrong on a lot of fronts and you
know we were wrong on a few fronts which
you're about to get to but you know the
basic basically the idea was
we we approached the world
scientifically and evolutionarily and
the the second is a subset um of of the
first and not everyone who has a
scientific toolkit has an evolutionary
toolkit
but boy would we love to be able to
help other people use those toolkits to
make decisions for themselves and to
start tracking when it is their own
predictive abilities are getting better
and better so that they can trust
themselves more and more and rely less
and less on external authorities who oh
by the way may have interests that do
not align with yours okay so i want to
go back and refine one thing okay you
said we could have been really wrong
okay
not worried about wrong
we aired in the right direction we aired
in the careful direction and we have
done that from the beginning and we did
get some things wrong masks are one of
the things i personally got wrong okay
but i got it wrong in the correct
direction and one of the things that i
think you and i
got
the
got attention that was very positive and
i hope people will remember is that what
we did was we started with a model that
effectively assumed this thing could
transmit any of the ways that these
things transmit and as data came in and
it became clear that this wasn't fomite
transmission that
there was something very important about
the volume of air and the rate at which
it was turning over so that it wasn't
like you contact a particle and you get
sick
it's like there's a period of time
there's a clock ticking and the air
circulation and the volume of the room
and how sick the person that you're
talking to is all of them play a role
and so we built independence at all of
the all the stages of interface between
virus and person right and we um you
know we uh used what we called uh you
know um
i'm now forgetting the term we applied
to it something like the uh the real
volume of the room or the um the
effective volume effective volume
effective volume so a car is a very tiny
effective volume you open the windows
the volume jumps you go outside the
effective volume goes to infinity
where you don't have the ability to open
windows you expect
expect things to be bad and i do think
um
you know we we never
as much as we were erring on the side of
caution
uh neither of us ever
thought
it was necessary or a good idea
to um be applying those kinds of
measures outside
outside we understood and you know i
found a i found a paper very early that
had come out of china very early um that
it looked that it tried to track the the
origin of tens of thousands of cases
yeah it was um and and it was um there
was i think only one case out of the
tens of thousands that they could
actually track to an outdoor
transmission and it was a very very sick
person talking at very close range
loudly to his neighbor if memory serves
and um
and effectively he was you know right
the the recipient of the virus in that
case was right in the funnel of you know
an active infection and
you know that
i am i am very grateful that we weren't
we weren't wrong on that because
i i think you're even being too cautious
here right because i think the real
story is
um there was a an opposing force right
there's this thing i think the original
is rahm emanuel who once said uh never
let a good crisis go to waste
right
rahm emanuel being a democratic
political gunslinger effectively but i
think what happened the best case here
right the best case is that people took
advantage of a crisis to accomplish
things that they wanted to accomplish
anyway many of which are very much not
in the public's interest but i think you
and i ended up
on the opposite side of a conversation
with an enemy we did not know existed
right which were people who were using
the pandemic for purposes we thought as
you know as a normal person would that
we're all in this together we're all
faced with this virus and figuring out
what to do about it is
a project everybody should be involved
in and people should be bringing
whatever tools to bear
that they have at their disposal
and
i think what actually happened is that
as
you know
this thing wanted to create fear
right it wanted to create fear
and it had useful tools at its disposal
that were also potentially in play with
respect to controlling the virus
so it pretended
uh after it was clear in the data
that the outdoor environment was safe it
continued to pretend that it wasn't
because its purpose really wasn't about
the virus its purpose was about
controlling people and so
you and i became increasingly alarmed
as this thing insisted that the outdoor
environment was a place that you needed
to mask in our point was there actually
isn't any evidence of that so as you and
i developed uh a model of how the virus
functions how it transmits and what
therefore we could relax about the many
measures i mean remember we're talking
about going out with
sacrificial gloves with uh with safety
glasses with
uh a mask right what of this can we
relax because it's actually not relevant
to the transmission of this pathogen at
the same point you and i looked at the
evidence
and it was quite clear that there was
something about the outside environment
that was safe it was unclear initially
whether or not it was safe at night
because one of the reasons it might be
safe was uv light
right and so it became clear actually
that there were two reasons it was safe
outside one was uv light but that even
at night this was not transmitting
outside
and so the point was what we were doing
was refining a model starting with a
very careful overly careful
response and refining it and relaxing it
as
uh
as
as it became clear that you could relax
it and my point about the mass mandates
which ended today
is that we are watching
that other thing which had other
purposes finally having to admit
that it was being overly restrictive
yeah we can talk about how we know that
that's what's going on a little later
but i think that you and i actually
forced the conversation to admit things
like the outdoor environment isn't the
same and to the extent that you're
claiming that you want people masked for
epidemiological reasons um
you know 99 of the world more than 99 of
the world is in fact safe and you've got
people believing that the world is 100
dangerous why would you do that yeah
well okay a few things one is i went
back and found this paper which was
published in 2021 but i've got the
pre-print from april 2020. you can put
it up if you like zac
um i was wrong it wasn't tens of
thousands it was a couple thousand um
cases that they that they were able to
trace um it was china um
as i said from
from january and february um so you know
this is this is extraordinarily early
and what we are told um was was when it
was spreading um so anyway not um not as
as huge a data set as i thought but
still still very large
um and then you know one of the other
things um that you know we were thinking
early on was well you know homeless the
homeless population is going to be very
at risk of this unless you know the
outdoors is protective and sure enough
we've seen no
uh evidence of super spreader events
either or you know or super spreader
or just
massive spread either within homeless
populations or
among protests right and so again people
will remember i think that by
um sort of april and may of 2020 there
had begun to be protests by people um
objecting to
uh to lockdowns and you know as i
remembered it was mostly about lockdowns
and it was mostly people
um who were identified by the mainstream
media as being right of center
regardless of what their politics
actually were i don't know um and these
protests were decried widely right like
this this was going to itself cause more
spread of covet and how dare these
people how selfish and then within weeks
of those protests
george floyd died and the protests of
course erupted first
first in
minneapolis and then throughout the u.s
and then throughout the world really and
there were just massive protests you
know here in portland i think it was
over a hundred consecutive nights of
protests that then reliably became riots
and um and at that point
that
over a thousand i think i think i do
have that order of magnitude right over
a thousand health professionals declared
that the real pandemic was racism and
therefore these protests were not just
justified but actually necessary
anyone who still thought
that we were living in a world in which
we were being given advice based on data
and not on ideology could pretty much
conclude at that point that at least a
substantial portion of the health policy
and public health apparatus was
completely out to lunch
and you know not in fact doing what the
job description suggests doing
that said
as much as those protests especially at
the point that reliably in portland and
some other places they turned into riots
every night
during the summer and and fall of 2020
as much as they were disruptive of an
incredible amount of of humanity and
goodwill um they were not super spreader
events any more than the protests uh in
the spring of 2020 against the lockdowns
and and such were super spreader events
any more than um there were there was a
lot of transmission among homeless
people and the common theme in all of
those is of course being outside yeah
which we predicted actually at the point
that uh many
were saying
you know we were talking about the blm
riots and saying these are going to be
super spreader events our point was
we're not in favor of these riots as
we've described many times right it's
not clear that these are a hazard in
this regard right you and i went uh to
see for ourselves we few times yep
knowing that the outdoor environment was
likely to be safe but being concerned
that this was highly concentrated and
taking place at night where you didn't
have uv light as a disinfectant um and
there are people yelling right i mean
yelling and
singing such as it was um
yeah toneless but
yeah but anyway you and i urge like
protest
songs
yeah dirge
that's being generous but um but you and
i behaved
exactly consistently with what we've
described here right we believed it to
be safe on the basis that it was outside
and we knew what the evidence suggested
about the outside we knew that night was
probably safe but you and i kept moving
so that if we were downwind of somebody
who was sick we would not we would have
a high enough effective volume around us
that we wouldn't contract the virus so i
think we now know that effectively
especially early on in the pandemic it
simply wasn't transmitting outside night
or day
that it would have been safe but airing
in the direction of caution is the
refinement we've done that and we have
relaxed our approach as it has become
clear that certain things are safe and
other things are not okay can you go to
the next photo zach there's you sporting
the uh chili pepper bandana now i will
say it's my uh that's my tropical
bandana that's what that is yeah um so
as the pandemic
continued
it became clear so i had initially
thought that cloth masks would be
sufficient because the droplets that
were being transmitted were large enough
that they would be caught it became
clear that we need to keep that up
uh we can move on okay um
it became clear that if masks were going
to be useful at all that it wasn't going
to be cloth masks so um moving away from
cloth masks uh was a move in the other
direction right not masking outside was
a relaxation moving to masks that were
more likely to be effective
uh was a move in the other direction but
anyway the point was we were developing
a model
this is zach and me in the elevator as
we were disassembling the the downtown
studio to close this out i just want to
point out
we have traveled the full gamut right
from as far as i know me being the first
person in our environment to mask at all
right i was masking before you know this
was a million miles from a mandate at
the point that i started masking because
it seemed likely to work it was
resentful right you were like you you're
going out to you know you put on a mouth
right but the point is you know what
when there was no evidence about how it
transmitted it made sense to behave that
way as the evidence came in and it
became clear that cloth masks were
ineffective then if there was going to
be a mandate it should have been about
masks that stood a chance of working and
at the point it became clear that this
was not an effective way of controlling
the pandemic we should have gotten rid
of them because everything has a cost
and this one has a particular cost to
children that we should never have known
yesterday in this case there are some of
the costs that we can absolutely see and
i remember
oh maybe i don't know 6 12 months ago at
the point that one of the associations
for child psychology i think it was uh
came out publicly declaring that there
was absolutely no impact on little
children in like preschool
interacting only with masked kids and
then separately and i won't be able to
call it up now but a couple weeks ago
uh the cdc
quietly and without saying anything um
changed the benchmarks for language
development for young kids and the
number of words that kids are expected
to know at various benchmarks has now
gotten pushed back by six months in
several cases why huh i wonder what
could possibly be going on in the world
for the last two years that would cause
all of the american children to suddenly
get dumber they're lowering the goal
posts yeah they're fully
lowering that yeah lowering the goal
post yep
yeah yeah
so anyway i think i think for the people
uh watching it is worth thinking about
what it takes to drive people who were
as interested in figuring out what the
best practices were to control this
this virus
as
i hate to say they've driven us crazy
but they certainly may
they have
uh tested our patience remarkably by
pretending that all of these measures
have utility they don't when the
evidence doesn't support them and um
you know it's been a profound a profound
transition
[Music]